we're starting off talking about
Southeast Asia in this series for those
of you who were here last week you
remember that I looked at the economic
growth rates for major economies in the
US and also Asia and we found that a lot
of the jumping-off places to China like
Singapore and Hong Kong and Taiwan and
maybe even Korea experienced dramatic
reductions in their economic growth over
the last two years partly this may be
due to the economic slowdown in China
itself which is also its growth rate has
has dropped but in contrast Southeast
Asia they have had some blips but
they're actually maintaining economic
growth rates higher than the world
average so in I think it was Malaysia
had a six point five percent growth rate
in 2010 and then dropped a little bit
but it's back to a 6.0 growth rate or
something like that for this year you
can find my slides from last week and
see what they were so we're starting off
with Southeast Asia to find out why
Southeast Asia is playing some sort of a
special role especially in the
entrepreneurial sector in the startup
sector we've got two great panelists who
are practitioners as well as teachers in
this regard sitting closest to me is Don
Tran who is the chairman and CEO of a
company named GES Inc and Don has over
20 years of experience in the
semiconductor industry he's worked in
all kinds of vice president and other
executive positions and product
development global business development
sales and marketing on the technology
side and the companies he's worked for
include groups like Matson Technology
semi tool Silicon Valley group and
Watkins Johnson he's also the co-founder
and has been an executive officer of
three high start startup companies in
the semiconductors
space so GES is a turnkey itech
semiconductor and production equipment
design and manufacturing company they
make the equipment to make the chips and
it has operations in the US and in
Vietnam and in India and I think I'll
ask Don to give his comments first and
then I'll introduce dr. ed rivesh who is
an adjunct faculty member of Thomas at
university in China and also a serial
entrepreneur I'm sorry Thomas hot
University in Bangkok
Floyd Ian slips right
and so Eadie is also a serial
entrepreneur in Thailand and has started
I think four ventures right yeah
including one that is in the late stages
of growth and maybe even looking public
in the future which we all ask you about
because that would mess things up anyway
let's ask Don if you'd give us some your
prepared comments first about Southeast
Asia of course thank you it's great to
be here I'm doc I'm Don trainer which I
introduced to me when he said great I
mean at you know before I going to talk
a little bit my about my company the
reason I will talk about my company not
because I want to market my company
today the more solar I wanted to share
with you you why did I get started in in
in Southeast Asia I start a company and
what the kind of capability that you can
back access to and got kind of money
what kind of possible you see right
today but before I start off you know
when we talk about what the role of
Southeast Asia in a global strategy
particularly in the high-tech you know
yeah don't follow you all right okay
but really you know the cellphone that
you have the smart I Pat you carry you
know the car you drive the television
you have at home to parents
meaning at home majority of doors are
made inside Shh I believe it or not
right so we so the technology the
high-tech Natalia Allah you know it is
the role that ceviche play it's a
high-tech area it's a very enormous and
then a lot closer to you too for your
daily life today right you know for the
solar the medical device the automobile
derived the LED that you about LED light
that you about to change in your your
house your clients are now when majority
are made it in made in so a two-out
number of the number of years that that
get investment in foreign company to
come in you know that infrastructure
being built resource and being trained
every second aside you're really
dividing your well I divide my time in a
bit between you know like a quarter in
India 40 in US and Florida in Japan and
a quarter in Vietnam and the rest of it
in the airplane yeah occasionally I get
to go to Europe you know for the visa
customer and whatnot you know yeah a
long time and the rest of time are at
the airport or somewhere some hotel
cheap hotel in Europe so I haven't
looked at yours long yeah
so kind of kid kind of give you the
introduction which is into the talk and
then I give you a little bit about my
company but again you know the purpose
is to share with you the capability and
an example of a company in Asia in
Southeast Asia and what kind of
capability resources and possibly that
you can access to to build your company
and operate
so how company like Richard introduced
you know we in a semiconductor relate
and related technology such as solar LED
and and displace those of you know
technology derived from from the
nanotech
you will to semiconductor technology we
are in in the design help the customer
to design equipment to produce the
device we are not we are not a device
manufacturer but we produced those
equipment to help produce those device
you know it's like Sola to put on your
on your roof or the LED light the chip
that can operate your LED and display
that flat panel display your LED
technology that now you see in the
Samsung then you know a PD and then all
those devices that you have in your iPad
and your your your Samsung Galaxy and
whatnot so okay we start a company I
found its company in early of 2007 and
immediately you know we we see the
opportunity in Saudi shave and so we
when an investment right away in in
Vietnam then we establish subsidiary in
Japan and then a couple years later and
we acquire a software company in India
we invest about eighty million dollar
per US dollar in the community today you
know we start out with two person today
we have more than one hundred and eighty
employee you can give you an idea that
the possibility of how fast you can grow
the company and and just plenty of
investor and institutional as well as an
angel investor that we're willing to
invest in the company that that that
want to do business our base out of
Southeast Asia you know our company
invested by a couple of Japanese
institution one if they do venture
capital I keep on base Allison tjuku and
then the I don't want to develop on the
Bank of Japan matter of fact we were
very proud of to be to be the first
foreign company that invests by did this
dbj and this dbj they only invested in
a large company like Japan airline you
know they bailout Japan Airlines the
sort of thing that kind of Federal
Reserve a very big and then the IDG the
venture Vietnam deterred an investment
arm out of Vietnam but it really did a
headquarter been in Boston Jim if you
heard of IDG international data group
they're very successful you know the
company we were also fortunate to
attract you know well-known people in
the industry you know for example dr.
dan made and one of the heart fame
Silicon Valley Hall of Fame you know
former president apply material one of
the largest semiconductor equipment
company in the world and then Robert
McKnight you know have been in the
industry for many years and absorbed by
and so of many companies and successful
and and dr. Henry Wayne is it the
mansion
Jeremiah partner of IDG venture in
Vietnam he also he's fun to have a
hundred million dollar fund he invests
all over Southeast Asia in the
Internet's paid in the mobile game you
know of e-commerce and whatnot an
enduring win it's also one of the well
known my person in in in the Silicon
Valley he found many company and got
applied but you know one of them is it's
a system design we I had quarter here to
quite small in US and San Jose but but
we put a lot of investment in Southeast
Asia one of them it didn't in Ho Chi
Minh City Vietnam that that we own that
building you know we build that building
from scratch and we we own that and we
that where we we do a lot of design work
we bring we do a lot of manufacturing
and if we provide aftermarket service
that meaning that one we design we
manufacture the equipment and and the
people that from Vietnam that they go
out to the world through the location of
the world war ii the do the installation
provides the equipment services the
the point that I'm bringing up to you
that point that mean that that today it
you know the Southeast Asian people can
go anywhere in the world right there's
no limitation anymore yeah just till you
need to acquire some visa and whatnot
but but it just it become much much
easier than many years ago right and a
couple years ago
we we didn't have the software group
software capability as particularly in
in in our few that we can find in
Vietnam or in in in Thailand so so we
look elsewhere we look where where they
have the best software and so we acquire
a company in India we have about sixty
people
software engineer in India and we have a
subsidiary in in Japan why is because we
have a lot of customer not only investor
from Japan but we have a lot of customer
a lot of equipment om the OEM Original
Equipment Manufacturer that day one to
outsource to to company that have a low
cost you know operation base like us and
have to capability okay so we again do
we very focus on on high-tech production
equipment we only do low volume high
precision I can fake and complex type
the reason I pointed pointed out it
people will look at it and say really
you know in Southeast Asia you know yeah
and I would say yes meaning what meaning
that the resources it's a we have a
skilled resource and talent be able to
provide this sort of thing that you can
be that nificantly unheard of you know
few years ago today yes we can yeah we
focused on electrical mechanical design
and bring it to assembly we also do
automation and and and and bring out to
a few and then we take care of update
and life entire life cycle of the
product that that we help design and
bill that mean that we provide a whole
gamut of turnkey of a product you know
why we doing it we're doing it because
we want to take away the thing that that
the company in us as Japan or in Europe
that's has spent a lot of time money on
overhead and and and that become a
burden to them so if they are outsourced
all adult of that and they can focus
their often their money into we're mean
the most which at the Rd words it's a
technology right the you know because
today you know it's in Southeast Asia we
have resourcing capability we can handle
this this this engineering stopped and
in the manufacturing job we have any
enough technology and we have enough
capability to do to do so there's
especially the supply and material
supplies change right again this isn't
another so what do we do we in in
actually in Vietnam we have a hundred
thousand square feet of spade and and
and we build cleanroom we have a hundred
people there we take we take order from
from the engineering work our way to
assembly to int'l a shin few service and
aftermarket ok so it's here to some
about product right so for example
semiconductor this is the one of the
state-of-the-art semiconductor equipment
on your leopard screen and we get into
LED this is where we you do y bonding of
the device that gonna put into your LED
light and we do robot you know we design
and produce robot that the semiconductor
grade that carry wafer you know it ultra
clean type of wafer that that's used for
your some a semiconductor device device
and they do flat panel right we build
equipment to inspect the array on a flat
panel so I kind of give you a some
examples of the technology that that the
South Asian your resource that can it
can manage this slide to tell you we
compete globally good computer would
compete
for global customer not in touch at the
regional market we compete for customer
from all over the world right you know
and we believe that we can be the best
you know and then the question of many
years ago and said you go into Southeast
Asia and you think you can make can
compete globally yeah a few years ago it
may not be the case but today you know
especially the last few years you know
we can confidently say yes yes we now
can compete then how would that happen
you know what that cultivate Kotov aid
that kind of kind of foundation you know
very simple you know the growth in the
region right as a dividend that from the
decade of globalization and FBI FBI I
mean a foreign direct investment that
helped the economic growth like Richard
allude to earlier today and the middle
class the rising middle class educated
population now the internal market it's
huge internal market the mobile you know
the the social media users you know you
you know combined seven country in
Southeast Asia you know the six hundred
million people that account for 10% of
the market now if you you know you know
Ericsson recently given out a data there
market for mobile phones is comfort of
seven country in Southeast Asia 13
billion from 2011-2012 that 78 percent
jump from year to year but you know what
the interesting point is that has it
only account for 25 percent of all
mobile in Southeast Asia so you can see
the market growing and then as people
get richer they can't afford to buy
automobile you know more electronic
stuff you know the did especially a
mobile and it's a lot of investment that
coming in into and then a lot of people
are betting on the mobile for social
media users like
Facebook they did really well in South
Asia integrand but big in in in Thailand
right that where the untapped
competitors you know a competition why
did you know when you're talking about
internet penetration that's the wrong
matrix yeah talk about wireless you got
to talk about mobile right because it's
more expensive to put in landline you
know and so everybody in a Southeast
Asia you have a phone even a farmer you
know in the rural country have a
telephone so that is your market and an
infrastructure due to due to you know
logistic patrol you know freeway
you know port being build using FDI in
investment and then out of that you have
you know and then the globalization
allow the student to study abroad and I
see in here you know many many
generations a student here that's the
evidence of and then this people are
coming back to to South Asia you know
with all the education all the knowledge
and and and that's a resource that
availab available to you and not only
that it also acts back
why not a fast internet connection low
cost living beautiful beach good food
why not you know that the plate that you
wanted to start up your company and on
top of that its reason for for outgrown
you know in the last few years I've
because availability of material that we
can be used in in in in the high-tech
innocent my conductor you know a few
years ago that we are struggling and
because labor cost you're low labor cost
it's never sustainable right
we are don't bet on low labor cost
because that's not sustainable we are
betting on skill quality you know and
combine best cost okay so that that kind
of yeah you know give you an
introduction of what what is about so I
gotta ask you a question
I'm gonna get set up for
presentation but while while I'm
changing slides around equipment design
and manufacturing right is one of those
kind of old-style technology industries
yesterday a world did you attract
investment when people are all after you
know Twitter clones well you know she
just not up you're talking about the
market growth in the mobile plan yeah
Southeast Asia right well obviously I
went into the wrong business right but
in reality is is the if you start up a
semiconductor equipment company in us I
think it's almost impossible to raise
money right some almost impossible no
but didn't you know and then then she
didn't but for us the attraction is that
that you know because evolution of the
industry that people you know first of
all audio production in Asia of seventy
percent in Asia art everything shipped
from from from Europe okay I want to
follow up on that a little bit in your
discussion you said you're competing for
global customers and that you had said
earlier in your talk that you were
really looking at the resources in
Southeast Asia including people and also
access to materials and so forth to what
extent do you think the growth of things
like manufacturing industries in
Southeast Asia in those markets did that
really has it contributed to your growth
didn't Intel build a plant in Vietnam in
Intel build a plant in Vietnam you know
so and did they do plant in in in
Malaysia and in other places as well you
know in China it's yeah so so yes in in
a way that did it because of the growth
in in associated that blew more and more
company high tech community to grow and
and why are they coming in it's not
everybody we cut costs because they are
seeing the growth of the in tournament
regional market yeah you know either you
earlier discussed that more and more
people using the technology content
right
and one last question before I asked ed
to talk what would you say was the thing
that has been the biggest new thing that
you've learned since 2007 was the change
in the market change the direction of
the way things developed or was it you
know the whole kind of well you know you
know that's an up and down you know the
economy is up and down but that we from
from the from the regional standpoint of
we we see more positive you know we see
growth that we see things changing for
the better and you know that's a lot of
challenges you know just looking back a
few years ago you know there's no such
thing of credit card use in in Vietnam
all right today you know we have
e-commerce right yeah so that that
changes right a few years ago that we we
come in and people say we're going to
try to ship the equipment and people are
strapped ahead and say how today you
know we you know it's it you know so
easy you know it's a no-brainer anymore
so those those are the thing that enable
you and in and of course they're like
economic growth you know for the last
few years you know and you know you know
you always see the positive thing here
again you look for the positive thing
Don you're not quite off the hook yet
because what I'm gonna do is ask ed to
give some comments and then we'll come
back and we have a Q&A and sort of
general discussion right how do we do
this do you want to sit here is that the
easiest thing to do or either one is
mine yeah okay great I'm in fact
actually the president presentation we
just heard from Don is a perfect
introduction to a little of the work
that we do for may I see some faces that
we've seen over several years so you
know a little bit about the work that
we're doing in Thailand and in fact
actually is probably that he left the
room we're trying to break out of that
because we consider that this has been
the strength of Southeast Asia in the
past and now what we're trying to do is
move towards what might be the next
so there's no doubt the manufacturing
capabilities of Southeast Asia Thailand
more were based but all the other
countries in the region are very very
strong and the key is how do you move
out of that to higher value stuff now
some of you who were here last year saw
that I told you a little bit about our
way of thinking which was fear the known
and I would just build on that a little
bit it's not the same presentation
okay so bill in a little bit about how
we're we're doing things and where
that's leading us hopefully beyond
manufacturing and contract manufacturing
which is a valuable service but it's
it's a service it's very competitive
don't make a mistake Don's company is
doing design well that's true this is
the key the design is this correct yeah
this is not the same as doing contract
manufacturing correct but and that was a
slip but the point is to move also out
of the manufacturing sector as well in
some ways ok yeah so so those of you
who've seen talked about we talked about
this last year a little bit while quick
introduction I've been in Thailand 20
years most of my work has been in the
auto industry before I got involved with
entrepreneurship development but I
started out with what I hoped was a
provocative statement last year I hope
it's equally provocative this year and
that entrepreneurs in developing
countries are more innovative than
entrepreneurs in Silicon Valley and the
reason I want to put that out there is
to provoke a little bit but also to
think about the process of
entrepreneurship and this this is the
key because the work we're doing is in
the development of entrepreneurs in
thinking and looking at things looking
opportunities in slightly different way
so I'm going to go through a couple of
slides from last year and review and
then show you how we've kind of taken
that on so you know the way I start out
this discussion I start out with a
standard you know some innovation theory
and and the the way innovation theory
goes is there's some people here that
might be called the cutting edge of the
innovators and there's this mass-market
and then there's here there's other guys
that don't get it that's kind of the
stock standard marketing definition but
a more important way of looking at it is
how that group of different types of
people
build a new market so what happens is
when anything is new the people who are
willing to take a risk on that newness
are the ones called innovators now it
doesn't mean they're necessarily wanting
something high-tech it just means they
have such a problem that's so important
to them they're willing to seek out
solutions okay so that's the people down
here and then goes up towards the Mars
the mass market where they're used to
having everything in place the financing
is in place the the brochures look nice
the operating manual works without typos
there's an 800 number or whatever the
equivalent is in other countries to get
help you know all of that stuff so
that's the develop a development of any
market at least in a theoretical sense
now we can say in that market any
general market that this is what happens
so in the mass market you know when a
when a customer buy some and in the mass
market they know where they are
okay whatever the product is you start
with a compact car and as you get a
better job you move up to a midsize car
and as you get a family you move up to a
minivan you kind of are put on a path
towards buying new products okay that's
what a mass-market is like but
innovators by definition at this point
innovators are always finding a path
they're always trying to figure out how
does this thing work I think there's a
value there for me I've got a problem
that no one else has been able to solve
how do I work that out and can this
thing help me so that's kind of the the
difference along this curve and then
there's you know of course people in the
middle you know who are kind of see a
path and they're willing to take a bit
of a risk on it and there's a whole
continuum as you know go through this
and that's where I made this distinction
you know there's no doubt that the
products coming out of Silicon Valley
the services coming out of Sylva Silicon
Valley even the design as we see here
coming out of Silicon Valley is
innovative but the important argument
here is that being an entrepreneur in
Silicon Valley is mass market all the
steps are in place you know who to talk
to where to talk to you know you even go
up on websites now and you know like
TechCrunch and it tells you exactly what
you got in angel and then what you got
in series
and be and you know a process is very
well-established okay and in fact it's
getting more established all the time
for those of us or me anyway who sit
outside and kind of watch it seems like
it's becoming like a supermarket you
know that things are becoming so
well-established in this process and I
almost think it sometimes I'm humored by
as you're gonna see later on in the in
the presentation it becomes very you
know the process of being an
entrepreneur seems to be like you're on
a flowchart and there's no way out of
that flowchart okay
so understand the distinction I'm not
talking about the products and services
and ideas that are coming out of it I'm
talking about the process of being an
entrepreneur and the reason that's
important is in developing countries
it's the opposite and that's that that's
the key challenge we have is that the
user experience if you will being an
entrepreneur you're you know you're in
the woods you've got to find your own
way you don't know necessary to talk to
who or who's likely to give you money or
what industries people are out there
supporting you know it's changing
quickly of course but it's much more of
a you have to find your own path down
here and it's true of course because of
that the products and services that are
developed often a little bit more
mundane they're more basic their nests
there more necessities rather than
cutting-edge products or services so the
situation is reversed and I admit trying
to be a little bit of a provocateur with
the with the comment but entrepreneurs
to be entrepreneurs regardless of their
product or service have to be innovative
as they go around and find their their
their path through this so basically at
the conclusion I'm showing you there and
I always put Fred Terman into my
presentation he inspires a lot of what
we do you should not graduate from
Stanford without learning about who he
is he's not just a name on a building
that no longer exists he really is
important to your history but he really
inspires the kind of work that that we
do because of the way he brought things
together I urge you to learn more about
the history if you don't so because of
that
one of the quotations I Zoey eyes I've
always loved with him and which inspires
me and the work we do is you know he
started out at a time when Silicon
Valley wasn't well there certainly
wasn't anything called Silicon Valley
you know it was Stanford at least in its
technical world was very far on an edge
of the map you know everything else was
done on the East Coast and he set out to
establish this place that you guys are
all in as a Technical Center and I've
always loved the fact that you know when
he started out west the world looked
very very big and we were really small
and through his efforts and a whole
bunch of other people's efforts managed
to reverse that and I think that's an
inspirational statement anyone who's in
in a area where you're trying to develop
entrepreneurship could do well by trying
to follow this kind of not the methods
necessarily but the the goal to
understand that when he started this
place was also a bit of a wilderness
when it comes to entrepreneurship and so
what that brings us to the stuff that
we're kind of doing his you know the
real opportunities of being an
entrepreneur so you're right
professor - are made a very important
distinction we're trying to break people
out of the manufacturing mentality or
the contract manufacturing mentality
anyway you know we're unfortunately they
are very developing market cause that's
the exactly thing right at the top you
know competing on costs because it's you
don't have a an advantage over anyone
else you buy the same unless you buy the
specialty equipment from Don you buy the
same equipment that everyone else has
yeah and the goal is to move down that
path and what we call that is not only
being willing to deal with the unknown
you know some people say entrepreneurs
are good at of of dealing with unknown
we say you actually want to fear the
known that the unknown is your friend
you know and that's the mindset change
we're trying to bring about and it's
hard to bring about if you're the
parents of our students many of who are
sitting here I have grown up on clear
markets by being a supplier to a Nike or
being a supplier to a well-known brand
it's hard to break out for the next
generation of entrepreneurs and say
now you're gonna have to find your own
brand in a mom and dad say why we didn't
have to so you know just ask you a
question about this chart you start with
what is kind of common thinking that you
compete on cost yeah and then really
looking at being willing to take the
risks of a new endeavor is something
that fewer people do you're moving more
toward the early adopter stage yep and
on down through thinking out of the box
and finally you really become a true
innovator when you get to this fear of
the known that you're a wimp you meaning
you want to avoid competition you want
to find the places where you're alone
and and we're going to show you some
examples where we're in that area you
want to fear where the hundreds and
thousands of people are doing it you up
because they'll be somewhere different
well you're all gonna you may even eat
each other up there may not be but the
point is there's gonna be a lot of
people trying for the same stuff whereas
if you can find these areas you know
fear the known part looking for the
areas where you've got some some and the
key here is developing countries have
those advantages as well okay it's not
just sitting in Silicon Valley finding
the new technology out of a laboratory
these same not the same opportunities
but equal opportunities exist in
developing countries in finding
non-competitive opportunities and that's
what what we kind of want to show you so
the next step that we take our people on
and that I actually urge everyone
because as I'm going to tell you in a
few slides I think there's a danger even
in a place like Silicon Valley try to do
this in your life okay don't even think
about as an entrepreneurship point of
view we're all being programmed to buy
products on a path to to live on certain
paths and what we need to do it
basically comes down to the world is
designed to follow a recipe right and
and there's nothing wrong with this okay
but you really want to be the person
creating the recipe okay so you can't do
this with everything you know we none of
us have the chance to research all the
products we're gonna buy and all the
services we're gonna buy but choose a
few places in your life whether this is
where your entrepreneurial life is or
your own personal life where you're
creating the recipes don't be taking in
and feel that you're always having to
follow someone else's rest
i'ma show you some examples following
recipe is a good thing but don't do it
for everything in your life okay
so sometimes it seems to me when we get
to some of our processes it's too much
like paint-by-numbers right including
our entrepreneurship development process
it's like do this then do this then do
this and you will be successful okay
well there's creative activities where
we don't have this paint-by-numbers
thing no matter how complicated gets I
mean you can even have complicated
paint-by-numbers but we can't strip the
creativity part out of it and we can't
build a recipe for that creative part we
need you need to be in that uncertainty
at least in one part of your life or one
part of your thing and so let me give
you an example you might you might feel
like I'm talking about things which are
not prevalent in our lives but I think
you'll see where this example and one of
our instructors here is a dive master so
I use this example listen you want a
scuba dive well Patti is a big dive
organization they've got your whole life
planned out here you start out as an
infant bubbling around in a pool and you
can all go all the way out through all
of these things and I think you'll just
see that all our products and services
are like that and we try to move our
students off of that both in life and in
company so let me give you just a couple
of examples before I finish you know we
call this write your own JD write your
own Job Description you know take
control of your life we also urge people
to think big in the scale and I have to
add I'm adding this one just for Silicon
Valley you know I do think that there's
a over excitement about mobile phone
apps you know there are some things you
can do without a mobile phone app and
that you you know the mobile phone apps
aren't likely to replace and and that's
where a lot of our opportunities are so
here's a couple of ventures we're
working on right now you Don talked
about the benefits of mobile phones you
know you can be anywhere you don't have
to put in Wired infrastructure how about
doing it with water okay this thing
allows you if you have any any source of
water ground water underwater or
whatever no matter what the the where it
comes from this can make you standard
water with solar energy you don't need
to connect to electrical grid you don't
need to be connected to a water grid so
distributed water supply perfect
for developing countries as you can see
here I mean there's 800 million people
around the world who don't have access
to clean water come from there's
actually two technologies one is
developed in Thailand another developed
is developed in Germany the Grady here's
a great example what was the role of the
University was this outside completely
outside the university but here's where
I should show you we're developing
countries have their opportunity this
particular one was developed by hoping
two German engineers in Germany for the
developing world well they have sold how
many 30 machines in eight years okay so
they've come to us to turn that around
they don't know the developing world
they know the technology but they don't
know how to get it out into the hands of
the people they don't know how to get
into rural developing countries so this
is where entrepreneurs and developing
countries also have a very very valuable
role to play another one which is from
students right here in the room you know
a lot of Southeast Asia is agricultural
still you know still 60 or 70 percent
the output of Thailand but a lot of
farmers are susceptible to cash crops
you know sugar rubber things like that
so this is a project to reverse that by
helping farmers plant crops that can be
turned readily into biomass this is
non-food crops for some of you might be
worried about the social impact non-food
biomass that can be converted in energy
providing a better return price back to
farmers and as long as we work on the
assumption that enterprise that energy
prices are not going down anytime soon
which in Thailand they're not going to
because the demand is far outstripping
supply then they will hopefully have a
more stable price even if it's a cash
crop more than sugar and more than
rubber which fluctuates up and down at
another end this is a model it's very
common in California but not so common
in Asia is to provide this is a
subscription service for organic food ok
which farm boxes are very common in the
Bay Area but what this is valuable for
is it provides market for small organic
farmers so it's not just that it's a box
to provide people who want organic food
it provides a platform
for suppliers of organic food so very
valuable for developing country markets
where the farmers need more income this
particular project also gets a lot of
artisanal foods you know cheeses and
sausage and stuff like that so we hope
it's going to encourage more food
entrepreneurs in some of the urban
markets and one of my favorites a breast
milk Bank
okay get some Snickers usually any time
I bring this up but it's actually a very
serious issue you've all heard probably
by now that kids raised on breast milk
are healthier than kids not but it's
even true for kids raised on breast milk
not from their mom so a lot of mothers
can't nurse for a variety of reasons if
the kid is born premature if the mother
is hiv-positive so having a breast milk
bank is very important and so this
particular group has been working to set
up a breast milk Bank for Thailand and
they're looking to expand that to
Southeast Asia so my point here is these
are all things that move into areas
which are not in direct competition with
anyone at least at the moment you know
they're completely moving out of the
traditional businesses and yet they're
in developing countries and take
advantage of the opportunities that are
in in developing countries so those are
the kind of messages that we try to put
under this heading of fear the known
don't go ahead to head with the obvious
markets but look for opportunities that
completely stand outside okay come back
up and join us and stay here I think
this is really interesting because you
really looked at things that are I think
the primary reason for where the
companies are as the market right right
I mean you're really looking at the
economic activities that are going on in
the market the opportunities specific to
the market you're looking at global
markets and you're looking at resources
from Southeast Asia I doubt if either
one can be said to be wrong yeah right
so I am curious in this global as a
globalizing world how those sort of
world trends impact what's happening in
Southeast Asia yeah yeah I was afraid to
ask me that because every time
professor Dasher asked me to make a
comment or a speech it's always based on
trends and I am the worst person on
trends I found this out some of you
heard a few years ago I was a licensing
director of licensing at National Lab
and you're supposed to be guessing
trends I can only think bottom-up so I
go project by projects unfortunately I
don't I don't understand trends very
well and I'm usually wrong when I hit
trends my company's been hurt several
times
means that you're seeing good market the
market opportunity yeah and you're
seeing a continuation of good market
opportunities how do you think the
situation in Thailand has changed over
the last five years well you of course
there's been a series of crises that
have been a problem back for that back
for the for the manufacturing people
that's been a problem and we've had a
little political problems the but I
think the opportunity is actually as Don
was saying there's the continued growth
of the middle class there's continued
growth of infrastructure throughout the
region and if Ozzy on the biggest thing
is ASEAN the attempts to integrate ASEAN
into more of a single economic community
which unfortunately has been delayed one
year but you know it's it's coming Don
actually I was really I'm glad to have
you as a foil to add this time because I
think that this kind of playing a role
in the world supply chain there's still
great business there and what you're
doing is clearly value-added you're able
to compete against large companies like
Applied Materials and these other
companies and they say my customer okay
so they're your customers
yeah but I'm curious how things look to
you how's Vietnam changed in the last
five years I never surprisingly it
changed quite a bit you know and you
know if you're going to give you example
I go to the restaurant here you know
people to service people to take order
of a note pack and I in writing when I
go to Vietnam maybe restaurant carry you
know the waiter and waitress today they
carry my pad or something
iPhone and I had some hack you order and
things to Des Moines oh that's amazing
you know you know traffic horrendous in
Vietnam but few years ago that's million
in a million a motorbike today the
traffic it caused by a growing number of
cars they concede he did look at it let
me ask you about the resources you're
dealing with the human resources a few
years ago I think it was really hard to
find people with a sufficient education
to do a lot of the kind of advanced work
especially design work but you know
that's a lot of room for improvement you
know in education the university is to
lack of you know resources and lack of
budgeting and whatnot you know but there
the government do a lot of thing to help
out and then they're plus they foreign
direct investment blessed a company that
coming in and so so the resources and
like I said you know people you know go
outside for study and expats coming in
so that combination that really help you
know and then I see that big improvement
in that okay so I've got all kinds of
questions but let's open the floor
anybody questions comments protection
and specifically in Thailand and some of
the other governmental infrastructure in
terms of normal laws and protections you
take a lot of things for granted here
that don't always exist in other
countries how is it Vietnam in Thailand
right now in Thailand both this is a
real important issue I would imagine
actually they're similar in both
obviously there is always the issue of
things like music and video you know
movies and DVDs and stuff like that
which is a you know a well-known problem
although it's also I understand they're
even available in the US if you know
where to look but so beyond that piece
you know if you're talking about
launching a company based on IP Thai
government certainly takes it very very
seriously and to be honest in my opinion
takes it too seriously meaning not the
protection of it but I think
we'll take the people in development of
science and technology are now taking
our valuing IP itself too highly and not
thinking about the business model not
putting in a proper business model it's
going off to the market I've worked as I
said I was a director of a TLO and
people just talked about protection
protection protection and never you
couldn't get the scientists shake the
scientists up to start thinking about
you know business models serving
customers and stuff like that so maybe
it's an overreaction the other way
people know they needs to be fixed but I
think it's probably overreact a little
bit too far now similar to Thailand you
know go and put in a lot of due respect
the IP is important for for for them to
educate people there's no way that the
comfort the country can grow you know if
we can continue to finish all the people
I pee in reality you know there will
always be a semi Frenchman you know some
copy money but all with employees taking
knowledge away yeah I'll address that
you know you know but yeah at the same
time you know you know we talking about
economic growth people start to wants
people to have money you know they want
quality stuff they want the rooster so
that become less invest and then you
know technology you know that's always a
way to protect it knowledge yet more the
advancement of Technology the more
protection you have so company would
would IP they do more that and make it
more more difficult at our company and
maybe pay a company in
we do you know we we also believe in
that we got to protect out our company
company IP as well our customer IP so
that that the world only way to do
business how do i you know better build
trust you know at the you know we're
developing country they Vietnam Thailand
developing country you know you got to
remove the barrier so the the private
that's where a commercial and sell
government they understand that you got
to remove auto barriers and the one of
the barrier it it you got to building
trust with your business partner so so
you will see less and less of the
concern of the IP protection we put in a
lot of IP protection policy and training
to our employee and I see a lot of that
also practiced in our peer companies
I've got a quick follow-up question and
it can go to either one of you or both
in some places if you have an IP problem
or if you have some sort of a legal
problem you don't want to rely on the
court system there are various
techniques that people have an
interacting with government to enforce
their rights separate from the court
system not just suing somebody what are
some of the things you're doing Vietnam
what are some other things you might do
in Thailand it's specifically with with
the courts in the government or or
outside in the marketplace either way
okay
I mean I think that's what however you
protect yourself separate from just you
know saying I'm going to sue you
yeah you incentivize people like to
start with the second guy and like I
said you know with the technology today
and we find way to protect our how I
feed us well our customer IQ okay most
the pointing our West you know respect
people like me yeah okay yeah again the
one I would like to make the distinction
between between music and DVDs which are
kind of special case they're a high
volume case but the reason or special
case is because they're usually in the
hands of corrupt officials as well I
mean it's it's an institutionalized form
of IP problem okay so keep that aside
cuz that's a different issue but the IEP
idea of losing I losing your competitive
edge to competitors through employees or
something like that I mean the the
simplest way is to incentivize your
employees well I think one thing that
hasn't always happened in the past I
think people with in Southeast Asia but
local companies and in some ways
companies coming into the region to kind
of set up have kind of viewed things
more of the commodity with their human
resources and when you turn that around
and start incentivizing people making
feel good to be part of the company then
they begin to respect it as well i
defending against IP is probably the
worst
I know Silicon Valley's an exception
because Apple and Samsung seem to enjoy
doing it but outside of that being in a
defensive posture with IP I think is is
bad business regardless okay good as
preparation for your talk today I'm
reading winner-take-all by a local
business executive Richard Elvis he
tells a story of how impacts basically
invented magnetic recording tape but
that akio morita and sony monetized it
you know first in the VCR which used
more semiconductors than any other
product in the world at the time and
then of course the Sony Walkman can you
give us in your thoughts on when do you
think that type of innovation will
actually come out of Southeast Asia
Asian
like is there an epidural an
organization of inventions no matter
where they're invented yeah maybe you'll
be first actually I'm looking at the
slides that you show yeah I mean it's
gonna be something it's gonna be
something along those we we like the
idea of a very innovative business model
taking something that might exist
somewhere else or was developed
somewhere else and getting it getting it
monetized to to that developing world so
something along along those lines
actually I'm thinking if you give me a
few minutes I'll come up with an example
it's already happened actually
you know hold it back to this town
refresh yeah the water station got water
for purification station yeah advanced
world advanced economies where you know
you can drink water out of the tap it's
not the kind of place where you find a
good solution to water problems where
the infrastructure isn't it's precisely
places that are developing that will see
the opportunities at the bottom of the
pyramid right in fact the contribution
we had almost right from the start when
we were working with them was in fact
this concept came from a guy in the room
here you know say let's make this an ATM
you know an ATM makes it so you don't
have to have banks everywhere you don't
you know so this is a you know an ATM
for it's an atw I guess you know or
whatever I get em there's not money as
machines but anyways it's a thing that
dispenses water you know at a single
point anywhere you want you know so that
was a really of thinking around the
business model that that's making this
an innovation when I work with the
scientists I say inventions and
innovations are not the same thing they
had the invention but they haven't
gotten the innovation until it's used by
people that's the so hopefully something
like that if but there might be some
examples which aren't well known but are
our recent successes let me let me think
about it before cocktails so maybe that
will be the last to notice but large
parts of the world and very large sales
will be achieved
these companies elsewhere before they
finally filter up to us anyway I good
Walter I have some what a coin and
substantiate the understanding about
doing business in hi there
when I speak of I we actually I sweat
know if the business doing so well
will there be some government official
interest in taking it over and I'll I
know look a Venezuela I don't know any I
don't know of any well there that's not
true there is a couple of famous
instances but that guy doesn't live in
the country right now okay
but in general Thailand in that kind of
situation doesn't happen in Thailand you
you will have like in any market lots of
people trying to you know several things
companies spring up to do the same thing
but I can't a man seen to Mason's
situations where a government comes in
to compete against yeah yeah between
people yeah yeah I haven't seen that on
institutional level are there non
business limits to growth for your
company you don't want to get to be too
big for some reason or other or because
there's some sort of you know it becomes
more and more difficult with the
government the more successful you are
are there any kind of limits to growth
in the businesses is doing on I'll ask
you first
other than the market or you know
customers eyes or what's a very
difficult question to answer
Blake of course there's always you know
some isolated case in there
you know that's good people and bad
people good officials that officials
people you know in this I saw a case but
overall you know what I that challenges
you know that limitation but - well I
did things with snow comes first
yeah this is to come
first yeah right and and there's a
competition you know it people see you
doing well you know of course some
official which government if so we'll
see that the look at the business and
they want to create the same way and
they use their power or influence - you
know suppress your competitor you know
it is it happen everywhere yeah and
you're not just in Vietnam and in
Thailand yeah you just got you got a
figured out your your your product
differentiation your secret sauce and
then compete from there and I think
that's a safe way to go follow the rule
I mean again not country little bit just
like Don said there are there are
individuals anywhere it can make your
life miserable so with tarah fresh for
example one concern we have is that you
know local at the local level local
influential people make water you know
so you know you could come head-to-head
with something like that but I'm from
Seattle and Boeing arguably has been
controlled and manipulative of the
government for a long time so you know
it happens in all kinds of levels but I
I can't imagine it at a you know they at
a countrywide level I could see it at
different locations but if you're
growing you know you have to you have to
create a relationship with the
government like any big business does so
I have a similar question to both of you
Don I heard that know some food winds
from Japan effects of you said a big
customer base from Japan funding from
Japan there also culture wise like a in
restaurant many images or we are using a
handheld or many people are cell phone I
think these are in points from Japan I
believe but did you see these kind of
employers of contribution from Japan
and a Python I didn't hear anything
I know influence of intuition in Japan
but that he used do you see any odor
these same from Japan okay so actually
marks question is a very interesting
question because for so many years we've
looked at globalization as having the
United States in the center and then
everybody else is a spoke out from this
wheel and yet here in Asia you've got a
lot of interesting things going on intra
Asia so Japan is a good example
what's how how does Japan play with the
Vietnam angle of what GES is doing ask
you that first
yeah it's acting it's a very good
question from from from our experience
you know and from our customer feedback
and whatnot and how they see Vietnam I'm
talking about Japanese customer and
Japanese investors and they see that's a
culture of similarity easy to do
business and then you know recent
conflicts you know where political
conflict between in China and in Japan
that that that make you know them look
elsewhere you know a fine alternative
you know to lower that risk you know so
they look obviously looking for country
that they can do business to it they can
they work with and then lower the rhythm
you know the Vietnam and Thailand shows
a couple years ago there's only a few
Japanese company in Vietnam today you
know that 2000 company invested in
Vietnam and that protect project to be
five thousand infants few years I
believe that fifty eight hundred number
of Japanese company in in in in in in
Thailand right now and so so in Tamil
but of how much of the influent of the
Vietnamese of course that a lot of it
foreign investment from from from Japan
they going to be subway in in the first
subway in Viet Nam in Ho Chi Minh City
you know the fashion you know with
Japanese product you know it is it
business did such a trait you know just
a fair trade so indeed that that sort of
thing or growing you know between two
countries you know
and a good relationship at date back to
fifty years ago way before the war I
ended and grecian the the Prime Minister
Abe a it's a very you know strong
proponent of Vietnam so his foot trip
out of out of the country its Vietnam
yeah after he got elected I sense part
of your question is about consumer
markets in is that part of it in general
is any contribution I mean obviously
heavy heavy influence but you know heavy
influence on on the industrial parcel
you know many of the Japanese carmakers
are there and in fact some of the
largest manufacturing operations outside
Japan in the US are in Thailand and
they're exporting all of the world so
industrially and then in consumer
markets of course snacks and beauty
products and all of that kind of stuff
although it's been overshot a little bit
in the consumer markets by Korea Korea
is more than the hot thing that all
these guys are influenced by gonna and
style and gun it's not gumming you know
whatever I don't know it gun them yeah
so you know the so there's been
obviously a long period of time for
consumer things but that did remind me
of one innovation I want to add at the
end you know 7-eleven for example is
very very strong franchise from Japan
originally US but from Japan and it's
really one of the most innovative
companies in Thailand and I would argue
that's more innovative in Thailand than
in Japan you they have catalogs in the
stores you can pay your phone bill you
can pay all your bills there you can you
know get your internet I mean it's I've
gotten and I'm not in love with the
7-eleven but I'm so reliant on them that
I can't stand going to a 7-eleven
anywhere else the rest of seblon is the
world just don't have the services so
they've met some of the Thai
entrepreneurs have managed to take some
of the Japanese service and product
offerings and innovate quite a bit with
them so yeah
you guys have already kind of alluded to
this but just to ask it in a bit more
succinct form about kind of my question
is what can Silicon Valley most learn
from Southeast Asia today or what parts
of Silicon Valley would you most like to
change based on your experience in
Southeast Asia you can whatever you have
thoughts about that second part you have
to change on your own so but the the
first part is you know the opportunities
in developing countries and there are
obviously groups on campus who are
working in that area the center of
affordable design and stuff but I mean
the developing world you know I always
love this term world class manufacturing
world class this or well that's not the
world you know world class is a very
small percentage and the rest of the
world is world class
you know so it's getting things out to
places that don't have highways and
don't have power and don't have stuff
like that so you know there are a few
people moving in that area here but I
would that would be the emphasis on well
I wouldn't change anything and I think
that's a lot for us to learn from
Silicon Valley you know this is my home
and I think is it the best place for
innovation you know a lot of times are
here you know as a you know people we go
through changes in evolution you know I
don't see anything that that you know
what we learn more about so you kind of
everybody wanted trying to be Silicon
Valley ourselves you know that's one of
the thing that that thing Singapore and
Taiwan and Vietnam and other developing
country and you want to be they wanted
of up a second battery by themselves so
so one of the dangers in talking about
Southeast Asia is you have very
different cultures very different
environments very different situations
in a nutshell what would you say is
distinctive especially for a start-up
entrepreneur or someone interested in
entrepreneurship what's distinctive
about Thailand what's distinctive about
Vietnam maybe you go first
so once opposed to other parts of
Southeast Asia yeah yeah I think one of
towns challenges is also what has been
its its advantages in the past I mean
it's a great place to be so it's a bad
place to try to make changes
I mean it's comfortable it people like
it it's warm maybe foods good you don't
really have to work hard to do anything
so you know it's it's hard to you know
have the drive to make lots of changes
because I mean is sub I write you know
the term that ties you just it's quite
nice to just kind of be you know we had
a session on the Philippines last year
and the panel said you should do it in
the Philippines cause it's more fun
there what's distinctive about Vietnam
well you know yeah I heard recently
somebody said the China is for trade in
India for trade in Thailand and Vietnam
and there's opportunity for investment
and I mean particularly in Vietnam
that's just you know our dough is still
communist country but it's a free-market
country for free there's a free economy
and it's a green fuel it's a lot of
opportunity a lot of challenges a lot of
opportunity and in the last few years at
the tremendous growth and the tremendous
opportunities or you know I say say it's
a good place to put the place to be ok
I think I'll ask the last question for
the session and that is if there was one
or two things but keep it no more than
two that should really like to change
about Vietnam about Thailand especially
in regard to being a more
entrepreneurial environment what would
you change
Don why don't you go first with that one
I'd like to see the healthcare get
improve you know you know you know how
kept you access to everybody whenever
you say something like that immediately
I think there's a range of opportunities
in this space and that certainly does
that there's a lot of startup you know
that focus on that space you know on in
pharmaceutical in
at a health care system okay interesting
and I think my answer comes directly and
what I was presenting I mean create a
mindset where people enjoy uncertainty a
little bit more you know that that
fearing the known and being really
really comfortable and in uncertain
open-ended situations so that's really
where we put our work and I think that
brings us back to the essence of what
you know this whole entrepreneurship
concept is about we've got some
refreshments outside hope you'll stay
around and meet our panelists and talk
with each other meet each other if you
would though please join me in thanking
them for a great time
you